death in The Fast and Furious movies
isn't entirely permanent it's
so well it may seem like these
characters have come to their demise by
the end of fast X How likely are they to
appear alive again
out of all the characters who meet
Grizzly Fates at the end of fast X John
Cena's Jacob Toretto seems the most
likely to actually stay dead for
starters he's a relatively recent
addition to the franchise having only
debuted in F9 that makes him a bit more
Expendable even though he is a Toretto
Jacob's whole Arc in fast X seems to set
him up for the noble sacrifice he makes
at the end his uncle nephew road trip
with little Brian is the most grounded
and emotionally resonant storyline in
the movie after seeing Jacob mostly as a
vindictive killer in F9 he gets to show
his Lighter goofier Side he does a
commendable job keeping Brian's spirits
up during terrifying circumstances Andy
keeps his promise to his brother Dom by
protecting him at all costs a sacrifice
from Jacob would make his whole
character a bit easier to swallow while
he does come back around to the side of
Good by the end of F9 he never really
redeems himself for the many violent and
evil things he's done killing him off in
a heroic way makes it easier for the
series to Grapple with that conundrum by
simply ignoring it so while explosions
have rarely been fatal in the Fast and
Furious movies Jacob's bomb car maneuver
seems like it may indeed be the last we
see of him
right before the end of fast X the
vengeful Dante Reyes has agency head
aims shoot down the plane that's
carrying Han tej Ramsay and Roman it's a
stunning twist after Ames initially
appears to Ally himself with dom Ames
blasts one of the plane's engines with a
missile launcher sending it spiraling
around the side of a mountain there's a
giant explosion but there's no shot of
the Interior as the plane goes down so
what are the odds that any of these
characters are actually dead well at the
very least Sun Kang's Han is probably
safe the franchise already spent like
five movies killing him retconning who
killed him and then bringing him back
from the dead taking him out now
off-screen seems highly unlikely after
all the work put in to resurrect him so
I got my postcard
plus fast X ends with gal gadot's
giselia shahr the love of Han's Life
coming back from the grave herself
there's almost no way the films would
kill him off before he has a chance to
reunite with her but since he is on the
plane we technically don't know whether
he makes it or not
also on the plane that Ames shoots down
at the end of fast X is Roman Pierce
played by Tyrese Gibson the de facto
funny man of the Toretto crew since his
debut in Too Fast Too Furious Roman's
fast X Arc is all about leadership as he
struggles to assert himself as more than
just a comic relief character he and tej
have a nice little moment of Brotherly
Love on the plane before they enter The
Fray and that's basically the last we
see of either of them so is Roman dead
probably not if Vin Diesel and the
writers wanted to kill somebody on the
plane it probably wouldn't be the class
clown that's just too sad Roman is far
from the most essential member of the
gang but he's been part of the franchise
since the second movie and he's way too
beloved to kill off so unceremoniously
plus he's gotten out of worse grapes
how in the hell are you not dead
that said it wouldn't be outside the
realm of possibility for him to make a
big sacrifice to save his friends at the
start of Fast and Furious 11. such an
act would mesh well with his leadership
Arc in fast X and it would kick off the
next movie with some heavy Stakes
tej played by ludicrous is also on the
plane when Ames sends it hurtling into a
mountain but is he dead like Roman the
answer is probably no while killing off
characters to raise the stakes is
natural at the end of a long franchise
killing either half of the classic Fast
and Furious comedy duo would be just too
tragic in fact it seems more likely that
tej would be the one to save himself and
the others by figuring out some
high-tech way to escape the explosion
given that Ramsay is there with him too
there's a good chance they could figure
something out for now though tej's fate
remains unclear like Roman he's been a
part of the franchise since his debut in
Too Fast Too Furious and it's hard to
imagine the movies without him at this
point
last but least on the doomed plane is
Ramsay from one angle she could be seen
as the most Expendable of the foursome
because she's been a fast and furious
team member for the least amount of time
Ramsay first pops up in Furious 7 as the
creator of God's eye the All-Seeing
computer program that can hack into any
camera on Earth God's eye plays a pretty
major role in the plot of fast X and
Ramsay even gets to show a bit of
remorse for how her invention is being
used so is she dead like the others on
the plane maybe but probably not though
she is the most recent addition to the
series who's also part of the crash
she's too established to be relegated to
an off-camera death and the God's eye is
still a major part of the plot going
forward plus the whole franchise has
also made a point in recent years of
developing its female characters more
thoroughly and balancing genders in the
cast Letty and Gisele came back from the
dead Mia returned an F9 and fast X even
introduces Daniela melchior's Isabel
sister of the late Elena Nevis that
doesn't mean that the series still
couldn't kill a woman like Ramsay but
her her death doesn't seem like the kind
that would really play well
one of the early casualties in fast X is
Luis De Silva's Diogo a Rio based Street
racer who befriended Dom back in Fast
Five when Dom returns to Rio looking for
Dante Reyes Diogo is there to help him
out sadly Diogo appears to die at
Dante's hands during their ensuing
street race the villain attaches bombs
to the bottoms of both Diogo and
Isabelle's cars and he detonates them
both Diego's Car Goes Up in Flames first
and he seems to die instantly as Dom
doesn't stop to help him out as he does
with Isabel the question remains though
if Isabelle survived her explosion why
couldn't Diogo have as well there's no
real narrative reason to bring Tioga
back in the next movie as returning to
Rio in back-to-back entries feels a bit
much but also explosions rarely ever
kill anyone in Fast and Furious Mr
Nobody doesn't show up at all in fast X
that's probably because as of F9 he's
likely dead but his shadow looms large
it's a big entrance for nobody
the former head of the secret
International Organization known simply
as the agency Mr Nobody was supposedly
killed at the beginning of F9 when his
plane was attacked by Jacob Toretto in
fast X his absence is felt severely when
Ames takes over the agency and decides
to go after Dom and the crew it's later
revealed that Ames has been in cahoots
with Dante Reyes for a decade though the
exact nature of their Association has
yet to be revealed fast X also
introduces Mr nobody's daughter Tess who
sides with dom and fights against the
agency from the inside you'd think that
if Mr Nobody truly were still alive he'd
come back to stop all the chaos
happening at his old job however there's
one line in fast Decks that suggests he
might just be in hiding while meeting
with dom and Naples Tess refers to her
father as missing with a curious pause
before saying the word does she know
something we don't could Kurt Russell
return before the fast Saga is over it
seems more than likely
well he might have been the big bad of
Fast 6 the Lesser Shaw brother hasn't
played a big role in the franchise over
the last handful of installments the
injuries he suffers while fighting Dom
and his family spur his older brother
Deckard to seek revenge by killing Han
though that obviously wasn't quite how
it went down Owen pops up again in fate
of the Furious this time as an ally to
Dom when he and his brother rescue
Little Brian from Cipher's plane once
the Fast and Furious spin-off Hobs and
Sean rolls around we get this confusing
little moment force me to kill my own
brother
but if her son really is dead Queenie
doesn't seem to know since she tells
Domin F9
are you looking for one of my sons
not tonight
so is Owen dead probably not the most
likely explanation is that Deckard faked
his brother's death to culminate in a
triumphant reveal in a future fast movie
also possible is that the relative lack
of interest in future hubs and Shah
movies means that the spin-off film is
non-canonical and will simply be ignored
going forward either way with Deckard
speeding off to save his mother by the
end of fast X Owen's ambiguous fate may
be cleared up in the next film
Elena Nevis plays a curious role in The
Fast and Furious franchise she's a
supporting protagonist in Fast Five and
in Fast and Furious 6 a temporary love
interest for Dom while Letty is dead and
then a point of Leverage in the fate of
the Furious after it's revealed that she
had Dom's baby Elena dies in fate at the
command of Cipher but she continues to
play an important role in fast X her
sister Isabelle becomes embroiled in
Dante's plot after Don travels back to
Rio and she'll likely return in Fast and
Furious 11. but what about Elena is she
really dead or is there some chance that
like Letty Han and now Giselle she could
be resurrected you'd think that she
would have done whatever she could to
get back to her son if she were alive
right well yes but there are some clues
in fast Decks that she might might be
coming back in addition to introducing
Isabelle who makes Elena Central to the
story again fast X starts what seems to
be the slow process of redeeming Cipher
at the very least it makes her a little
less evil and a little more helpful that
doesn't necessarily mean that she'll
become part of the family but her
Redemption would definitely be a lot
easier to swallow if her greatest crime
turned out to be alive
okay this one is a bit of a stretch
Hearn and Reyes gets shot in the head by
Lou Cobbs at the end of Fast Five not
only is it a visible palpable kill but
it's the entire setup for Dante's
Vendetta against Dom and the crew there
should be no doubt as to whether or not
Hernan is still alive but this is Fast
and Furious where no death should ever
be believed 100 let's say just for the
sake of argument that Hernan is still
alive it could actually fit quite nicely
with what Dante does in fast X we know
that he's a trickster he shows it
numerous times throughout the movie
including at the end when it's revealed
that Ames has been working for him the
whole time what if his revenge Quest is
actually a ruse for what's really
happening do you like surprises I adore
them in the Fast Five flashback sequence
that kicks off the film Hernan tells
Dante that he has a plan to make their
family richer and more powerful than
ever apparently Ames has something to do
with that scheme though we don't yet
know how why would Dante wait a full
decade to track Dom and Hobbs down maybe
it's because his father other is still
alive and they were scheming in the
shadows until the right moment presented
itself Hernan Reyes is almost surely
dead but actor joaquim day Almeida came
back for fast X so what's to stop him
from returning again in the next film
never accept death
Jesse died in 2001 he was shot to death
by Johnny Tran and Lance Nguyen all the
way back in the Fast and the Furious
right in front of the Toretto house or
at least that's what they want you to
think if the core Fast and Furious saga
is truly ending what better way to tie
everything together than bringing Jesse
back he's the first major character to
die in the series which makes him more
deserving than any one of the now famous
fast Resurrection treatment he could
even be the one to save Dom and little B
from the dam or Roman Ramsay and the
others on the plane ridiculous sure but
in this franchise it's not outside the
realm of possibility just imagine Jesse
the original computer genius before tej
or Ramsay ever entered the picture
working on God's eye modifications or
space cars or hacking into the agency's
Mainframe picture him in the climax of
the next movie still driving his beat up
Volkswagen Jetta wishful thinking surely
but again completely feasible given what
this franchise has done in the past it
just brought Giselle back the latest in
a long string of returns that includes
Han and Letty Jessie could be the next
Link in that death-defying chain what a
joy it would be for fans who followed
the movie since the first one to see him
ride back into action after 24 years
away
foreign
[Music]